man kann gar nicht zu dem hingehen
lassen flexibel weg als das jetzt fahrt
42 42
hey freunde und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge des megaprojekts
bei mir ist jetzt nicht all zu viel zeit
vergangen also ihr habt der täglichen
folge bekommen allerdings bei mir hier
zu hause ist jetzt eine woche schon der
vergangen und ich hab mir jetzt einfach
mal spark und supreme himmel eingeladen
die das ganze jetzt mit mir aufnehmen
werden erstmal an der stelle ich würde
sagen dass erstmals park laufen weil der
meinte der krieg und ich hoffe dass
jetzt auch erstmal hier alles an weil es
ist schon eine woche her dass ich hier
auf dem server und es hat sich eine
menge getan habt ihr vielleicht auch bei
den anderen schon gesehen vielleicht
auch nicht aber hier ist auf jeden fall
das parken paar sachen wenn ihr sehen
wollt ihr das gemacht hat könnt ihr
einfach backten kuchen
von meiner seite aus gibt schon ein paar
leuten gezeigt aber ich finde so die
reaktion lustig deshalb zeigt mario wolf
oder kuchen vorbei hier hakt bei mir
überall so ein bisschen das sogar japan
jagt auch gerade richtig
an dieser stelle aber nur hier so an
dieser stelle ich weiß welche so viele
sei jetzt geht's wieder vielleicht
welche so viele komische gut meine kiste
schon einiges drin
ich habe übertrieben ein bisschen älter
wie viele partner schon dass ich jetzt
fahrt 42 42 42 tasten du alter auch
lösen langeweile gehabt über als die
freien tage was wochenende ich konnte
wissen aufnehmen von daher keinen fall
schaden
ich habe solar hell mit dem helm mit der
das jetpack auflädt wenn ich da stehe
also soler zeit auf dem kopf ist voll
dieser daniel düsentrieb allen gerade
auch mit beilagen darauf lache ich gucke
einfach mal eine minute lang mit offenem
mund auf dem bildschirm
das sind eure musik seien schlecht
ausgehen dass alles auch beim fliegen
auf ich habe noch nicht über den kessel
laufen der es heißt er gibt kriegt er
macht euch dieses futter kommen dann
kann es am besten zeigen ins freie feld
hier blitzt sauerstoff also ich könnte
auch dich genau das mache ich lieber
nicht weiter
also bei mir stand einfach der sound ist
einfach richtig komisch blitzern und
habe ich noch etwas genauer gucken auf
dem boden gerade ein anderer zauberstab
jetzt in der anderen staffel einfach
blog tauschte zu sagen so kann man sorge
ob sie den farmen einfach da wo ist
dieses wort auf dem bildschirm teil 2
folge dass nach jeder ich will es nicht
war gerade bleibt bestehen
die blöcke mit dem ding
und ich habe hier noch ein tolles
schwert guck mal du kannst gar nicht
bedrohlich moment hier so wirbelsturm
macht man kann gar nicht zu dem hingehen
lassen flexibel weg alter
ich bin fast tot ist
freunde jetzt widmen wir uns hier wieder
den oder die spitex
dann würde aber nicht durch schießt auch
nicht
ich weiss es nicht ist einfach stehen
immer so central tower
ich hab mein start bei mir in der
wohnung gemacht hat hier keine ahnung
ich habe mich habt ihr hier platziert
weist den vollsten folge der sohn der
als geklaut gestellt damit einer der
übermacht dass wenn einer zum 1
getreidefelder runter läuft nun darauf
schießt und so ich meine was genau aber
ich glaube nicht dass da irgendetwas
dagegen gelaufen zwei mops laufen auf
einem coaching nicht rum
der mars reichen schicken oder so aber
übrigens zuschauer aufgefallen dass ich
diese wand hier zu komisch gebaut hat
und zwar würde ich das hier weghauen das
was man von außen nicht sieht damit ist
ein und einfach eher dahin packen kann
so und es haben sich auch relativ viele
beschwert dass ich doch nicht mal lauter
machen soll
panel on sollen wir nicht auch machen
ich habe kein bett kann vielleicht ein
haus ohne wissen des pk 42 patzen kann
hat irgendwie 46 tiere nicht im bett ich
hab dich 46 ich habe nur zwei 26 und 6
uhr trotzdem hatte ich schon krass viele
fans eine tolle verzauberte spitzhacke
die kann durch wände gucken und ich sag
mal gucken
ja sozusagen also inventar und drücken
schriften wenn du auf einen drauf zeigst
du siehst also elemente drüber gehe wenn
wir der pigs auf die wand haus zum
beispiel siehst du welche elemente sich
hinter dieser wand befinden bis zu zehn
blöcken wenn du halten zwölf fertiges
kristall element hast weißt du ganz
genau dass das diamant ist das heißt
einfach es sind hier nirgendwo mehr
diamanten zu finden quatsch dessen
tonnenweise der mann noch zu finden
ich habe unten und ich habe zwei drei
gänge gemacht bin entlang gemeint habe
einfach alles rausgesucht also es gibt
auch tonnenweise diamanten war es ist
gar nicht so dass diamanten so selten
sind also diesen relativ häufig ich habe
da nur 33 frost habt ihr auch nicht
gesehen
und zwar ist es im feld da macht er oben
so halt so kannst du so ein gebiet
festlegen und in dem gebiet meint er
denn alles weg bis zum betrag und so
kostspielig ist es noch nicht mal die
mining titel habe ich auch eine also
nicht auch schon über auf
da triffst du hundertprozentig auf
diamanten denke ich mach eins zu diesem
einigen turtles oder reinigt mal die
turtles ein ding was komplett sind
viereck alles runter bis zum betrag weg
da musst du dann so so so fackeln setzen
oder irgendwie so gelbe fackeln damit er
das erkennt oder wie richtig corrie
passwörter bei youtube oder so gekommen
wie kann überlegen ist übergreifend auf
die super wir hier weiter was frau die
auf der suche gibt welche ja so als
dankeschön für die aufnahmen denkt man
schon was da so 12 diamant nicht
rausspringen für das aufwendigste gegner
doch da habe ich voll was gegen die als
wieder zubereitet sicherlich könnte auch
bei diamant abgeben oder sogar so hell
nein aber ich habe gesagt ich bin netten
verteilung wissen weiß ich mache lieber
freunde als feinde und deshalb ich habe
auch weil viele leute haben sich hier
schon so halbwegs getötet unseres
technik und den anna und ich dachte mir
so ich will hier mit den leuten in
frieden leben und was aufbauen und nicht
immer angst haben dass ich gleich von
hinten
aber trotzdem ich schon vier mal
gestorben ich finde einfach dummheit
gestorben das war weil ich eine port
liga an gefunden habe ist eigentlich hat
mir so gesagt müssen verboten also weil
das problem geht wenn es mehrere leute
haben wir haben bis jetzt gibt es nur
zwei und ich hab dann simon der welt
messen müssen erklärte armstrong und baz
von einem loch zum anderen gesprungen
oder mich halt einmal raus und tod so
ganz plötzlich jemanden sich auch laden
wir die färbung werden dann einfach
alles mögliche rumprobieren der portal
ganz eine art und uns eine folge lang
einfach komplett die ganze zeit gejagt
und da hat er einer dann die portugal
gehabt und hat dann das jahr oben und
unten hin gemacht hast du ja also ganz
verlegen
diese kam es dann soweit dass man das
eine loch auf dem berg gemacht hat
irgendwo abkupfern das andere dann immer
vor dem gegenspieler der decke laufen
ist geschossen hat und dann resultierte
die komplette situation dann
letztendlich darin dass wir in unserem
haus welches im pc blöcke hofer oder so
ein trottel nach ganz oben gemacht aber
das andere direkt darunter das heißt im
wahn in einem unendlichen zyklus von
portier teleportieren und sind dann eben
mal rausgegangen dann weil wir direkt
rot zum erweiterten sich level verlorene
das model fall schuhe an die kannst
machen mit ob sie die reisen und für die
us-küsten wieder fall schaden wie konnte
ich mir zum glück leisten das habe ich
schon gemacht wann genau er einfach
alles
also wenn du mir jemand ist also ich
mein weg der situation weil ich bräuchte
gerechtfertigt wie lange halten die
sportschuhe und endlich an den bauch und
jappy ich wollte mir auch so viel schuhe
machen dass ich keinen fall schaden wir
kriegen hat ja gerade geredet was
gelernt ich wirklich machen sein sagte
jeff beck und dann wieder gedacht aber
hier sagt sie da so also uns bat wir nun
diamanten hast ja in dieser folge jetzt
schon oh ich wollte ja nicht so am ende
geben also ich wahrscheinlich etwa ich
könnte hier ein leben in der folge auch
noch ein
die jungs verdienen noch ein bisschen
mehr aufrufen und ich bin aber nur zwei
folgen dabei leute damit ihr erwischt
soll ich machen genau ich wollte jetzt
so nah so ein abbau zauberstab noch so
ein
das hat eigentlich links gebaut das ist
mir die ganze zeit schon aufgefallen das
ist etwa 2000 wasserkraftwerk hat einen
wasserturm gebaut der als ich so ganz
toll aussieht
es gibt bringt aber nicht so viel
energie jetzt also ist es nicht so der
berner
ich würde mir später lieber solar keines
man sagt einfach in das wirklich am pc
aber das liegt in der luft
einfach so eingebaut oder generell denke
ich mal ein heißluftballon
naja gibt alles wirke sich auch auf die
habenseite fliege der insel gehabt ich
war mit cash
die meisten ich habe mit cash und simon
waren wir auch unterwegs erkunden da war
eine fliegende inseln der fliegen in
silber ein diamant glock drin also so
wie jemand block genau block 1 werde
erst wieder bei lena da steht genau hat
jeder drei diamanten gekriegt ich hätte
einfach so gelacht wenn dieser block der
bei den da steht verliert im internet
geklaut wurden die bälle oft geklaut
werde nicht geklaut
aber ich glaub ich hab den auch müssen
zu viel geschenkt
16 stück alter gibt sich auch da wo
diese diamanten geschickt ja also ich
hab dann eher als ich so viele gefunden
habt diesen diamant für eine spitzhacke
ich habe mir noch zwei gerade gemacht da
kann ich ja gleich müssen weitergehen
habe ich ihren stack die ausweise
gefunden habe ich sagte was auf deutsch
so nett bin weil die beamten aufgenommen
microsoft gleich jeder zehnte von mir
und den also ich brauch noch zwei
diamanten eingang damit den symmetrisch
machen kann wegen vier blöcken gelb die
hat hier nicht gefällt ist okay erst
noch von 64 ist also es war ja ich weiß
sollte sich die apathie damit ich etwas
verändern kann
also ich muß ein wenig den output
reduzieren weil irgendwann werden
diamanten gar nicht mehr so selten weil
dann jeder so tonnenweise hat an deshalb
ist das nötig machen jetzt habe ich noch
ein monopol braucht erstmal eine rüstung
auf jeden fall
ich hab grad 128 118 schwede
hundertwasser und habe richtig fett ist
piratenschiff gefunden mit zwei
heißluftballons daneben war es unter
wasser auf dem wasser neuling aufstieg
ist wie weit bist du weg ich bin
ziemlich weit weg davon who
na ja also das ist heftig das muss
mittlerweile auch aufrichtig land
einfach laufen damit man dort findet wo
wirklich noch keine leute waren oder ja
manchmal hast du dich mal beikommen
gesehen was da hinten am strand war mit
den links aber ich glaube so weit war
dennoch nicht hoffen jetzt hier noch
keine ahnung wo ich sie schon durch die
durch die wand place ponor und kann man
erfahrung gute links
da die sind aber auch leicht op und
diese höhen spinnen charakter
ich hatte irgendwie 52 ländern
verzauberten mit 42 als wieder auf 42
war wie ich gestorben
die portman 232 ich finde solche
diamanten geben und dann
gucken wir mal gucken was oder ewig
genau das ganze zu fakt kommt die
spieler von oben runter alter schwede
spinnen sie noch parkplätze rüstung
machen wie sollte ich mir am besten ist
meine reise rüstung machen oder sollte
ich mir da irgendwie was mein anfang
flugreisen rüstung das beste von anfang
weiß dass er jetzt erst mal bisschen was
aus ich habe auch angst gemacht ich habe
jetzt ein jetpack zum beispiel das
brauche ich gar nicht aber ich lasse es
an damit sich auflädt ja ich dachte ich
gehe gleich noch ein kleines rädchen
diaz war so wissen die erste folge ist
auch schon fast wieder rum
wir sollten so frei wir sagen aber wenn
du immer vorbei ist übrigens nicht immer
noch leicht angeschlagen und plötzlich
passiert komisch an meine stimme okay
ich bin ja bei den sports zu zerstören
es gelingt mir auch halbwegs ich habe
halt mittlerweile echt schon mein
eigenes kleines erdfarben fällt die war
damals war hier wirklich einfach nur
fläche also die das jetzt gerade mehr
vorgesehen
andere finden alle möglichen und bauen
also nicht aber ich hab auch ich hatte
zwar derzeit beim ein grundstück am
anfang sehen müssen das war etwas lacht
fällt einfach das war so schreyer ich
habe gesehen dass ganze jetzt an terra
formen so ich habe auch mal über den
folgen mit reingeschaut
das ist das einfach das einfach nur
scheiße aus auf gut deutsch erst mal
aber ich hab das jetzt einfach alles
aufgestellt ich habe auch die kompletten
hingegen dazu gemacht und so das war's
einfach mal ich aussagen mit eisen
schwert praxis haben aber auch nicht
viel mehr schaden
[ __ ] ich bin gleich alles voller scheiße
und es brennt das schiff brennt
ich wollte doch noch kisten suchen ich
hab ja wie vorstände er aufs schiff
läuft von almosen wert wegspringen
explodiert einfach alles ich brenne
und jetzt kommt diese ganzen scheiße
fakt ist nämlich ab der grace nicht
geschlagen
ach du scheiße was geht bei euch alles
ab es läuft da sie dies natürlich
praktisch der blitz zauberstab hat eine
reichweite von zehn bis zwölf glocken
screenshot gemacht
scheiße alten ob man sagen einfach
richtig verdient aber gerade habe ich
mich richtig gefreut als er gestorben
ist ich hab das einfach mal sehen in der
fei scam was sowie grinst masse gleich
aber gleich bleibt aber in vielen
aktionen wo einfach interface camp schon
die uns leute mit harald feldkamp
erfolg wird an einfach während den
aufnahmen ist wenn ich lache das ist
dann einfach die willst ich hasse meine
einfach